[Music]
you're a freak
freak
[Music]
my dearest friend be very angry with you
if you died
[Music]
my sole purpose on this earth is to love
roxanne does she know the world will
never accept someone like me and a tall
beautiful woman
we have no money a clever marriage is
your only option i won't be rescued i'm
not in distress love does that mean
nothing to you children need love adults
need money
i need something to die for
write bones and cry for
and i won't be ashamed
light
[Music]
i have a confession to make i'm madly in
love perhaps he feels the same but i've
never actually spoken to him of your
love i think
he is christian christian
he's a new recruit in your regiment of
course he is a woman like roxanne wants
wit romance poetry i don't know how to
speak romantically i am a poet my words
upon your lips i will make you romantic
will you make me handsome she loves me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you are a
my fate is to love her from afar
[Music]
we must let her decide our fate she must
have the choice
[Music]
[Music]
you